The sauce, Kevin here,
and this briefcase contains the entire universe and everything that makes you
mad at a human.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, that's it. This is it. Paper, dollar, pencil, sugar cube, playing cards.
Rubik's cube. Let me explain.
Piece of paper.
Paper is about 4,000 an inch. And to get the number of layers after folding,
we make two to the power of folds. We start with one.
Then every fold raises that power. One more.
My folding is not going well.
The world record for paper folding is only 12 folds.
If we could fold it 30 times, it'd be thick enough to reach space.
42 gets us to the moon at 103 folds.
The thickness of this paper would be around 93 billion light years.
So basically the diameter of our entire observable universe,
a piece of paper is the size of the universe.
[Inaudible].
Inside this sugar cube. In fact,
we all are or could be Adam's are tiny and their fundamental particles are
even smaller. A proton is like a centimeter, one quadrillions of a meter.
The simple way to think of our bodies makeup is that atoms are a collection of
particles with a fair amount of empty space between them.
Quantum physics shows us that's not actually true,
and that a lot is happening and what appears to be
99.999999% empty space. That space matters.
But if we compress the atoms of the human race into a tight ball and ignored
what's in between them all,
nearly 8 billion of us would fit inside this sugar cube.
This is us 7.8 billion of us inside
here. We can't hold be unique, right? Right. No wrong.
[Inaudible].
108 Billion humans have been born throughout history.
If you're one in a million, like my mom told me, I am.
That means there have been 108,000 humans. Exactly.
Like you, that's not good.
How can anybody possibly stand out? I know. Just do something.
No human has ever done before. Like what? Shuffle a deck of cards.
Okay. People have done that, but not the same.
Michael mentioned this in his math magic video, it goes like this.
You've done 52 cards in a deck.
The number of possible combinations is 52 factorial.
So 52 times 51 times. 50 times 49. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah. All the way down to one. Cool. That's.
[Inaudible].
That number? Different orders of a shuffled deck.
Every time you shuffle and deal,
you've just created something that's virtually guaranteed to never have been
done before and seriously unlikely to ever be done again.
So ignore your 108,000 clones opportunities to be unique
are actually everywhere. And there's no limit to what you can do because you,
my friend, you, you, you watching this video, you're a super computer.
Uh.
Cube has six sides of a three by three grid and each square
is one of six colors. The question is how many permutations exists?
That's a good question. I think of it often he had just this 43 quintillion,
252 trillion, 3 trillion, 274 billion, 489 million, 856,000.
That's it.
And every single possible state of the cube can be solved in 20
moves or fewer. That's called God's number.
And it took Google 36 CPU, years of computing power to determine,
do you Shang soft? The classic three by three by three Rubik's cube in 3.4,
seven seconds. Maybe it takes you longer,
but you're mentally capable of processing any one version of 43
quintillion problems and solving it in a surprisingly low number of steps.
You solve problems in the world. And if you're like me,
you go outside once a month to get more peanut butter. And you notice, Hey,
there's other people around.
Uh.
Helps connect us. But you've got to think about it the right way.
This doesn't actually have intrinsic value money.
Isn't actually worth anything it's paper,
but it does represent a way for everyone to exchange what they've got a thing,
a talent, whatever for what someone else has.
The Aztecs used cocoa beans and the ancient Chinese used calorie shells.
I've got a PlayStation. I like making videos and I want a pygmy goat.
It's a lot easier for me to use something that allows me to transfer my old
PlayStation and my video production skills.
And then use that to buy a pygmy goat then to find a
pygmy goat farmer who really needs a PS one and a paradox video.
We have a system that converts what we've got into what we want and give someone
else way to get what they want with what we've got.
And it's not just about money,
currencies like love and trust and loyalty spent nicely too.
You can be you with others.
That's why we're capable of making incredible things.
Uh.
Such as a number two pencil it's like Leonard reads eye pencil.
It shows the sheer insanity of human cooperation that results in making
something as basic as a pencil, someone farmed the incense, Cedar,
someone built the tractors for that farm.
Someone made the wheels for the tractor, someone minds,
the graphite and clay for the lead. Others binds the metal for the Pharaoh,
no one planned this.
We just all did our little piece and others combine pieces with our needs and
desires to make a thing everyone uses,
but no individual person could ever make themselves.
We can't even comprehend what's happening in this sugar cube because it's too
complex. What does my universe paper?
We do all of this because we know what zero is.
It's not even just nothing.
It's the absence of value value that exists somewhere. Just not where zero is.
If infinity is so impossibly large, that we can't even really understand it.
Zero is an impossibly deep void.
We process mostly by what it isn't.
We do understand the power of something.
That's a placeholder to make an identify greater things,
but that on its own is sort of a terrifying lack
of meaning.
Zero makes the pencils happen and it's the absence of pencils.
It's never getting what we want.
It's never solving a Rubik's cube.
It's the inability to be unique. It's inaction.
It's an empty sugar cube.
It's being in this unfathomably large paper
universe and fighting against the prospect of being and meaning
nothing. You know what it is, but your everything,
because you're not zero.
The world is big.
The universe is complex and you can visualize conceptualize and appreciate some
of the most complicated elements of life by studying
and researching and experimenting.
But also by messing around with some of the junk lying around
your bedroom or stored in your extremely cool briefcase.
And it's always thanks for watching. Hey, real quick,
this video was actually sponsored by the Ridge wallet. It's tiny, slim strong,
and it won't bulge in your pocket. Are you still sitting on your wallet?
I used to sit on this beast all day. Look at this thing. I can't even close it.
I don't even know what's in here. Receipts. What is this?
I am real Kevin. No, you're not. No,
you're not get out of here. Give me back. My Ridge wallet.
This holds up to 12 cards plus cash,
and there's over 30 colors and styles like Burt titanium and carbon fiber.
They have over 30,005 star reviews and it comes with a lifetime warranty.
So you can buy one wallet and you use it forever.
You'll get 45 days to try it out. And if it's not for you,
you'll just return it for a full refund. Get 10% off today,
free worldwide shipping and returns by going to rich.com/vsauce two. That's
rich.com/vsauce to use code Vsauce to link down in the description below.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Hey.
The full curiosity box is 5% sold out.
So to get yours and secure your winter curiosity box, go to curiosity, box.com.
This is the subscription for thinkers to watch more of my videos.
Click over here,
to check out my podcast where we interview top YouTube creators.
Go over there.